thanks very much rich and thanks to you
and your team at the Yale College
Council for organizing this event and
taking seriously your responsibility to
you know put great events in front of
the Yale community this is really really
valuable and hopefully fun helpful it's
fun for me because I get to come back
and join three of my former colleagues
in the Economics Department and talking
about the current crisis center and a
member of our law school faculty and so
I'm very much looking forward to
tonight's conversation I do have some
views of my own but I won't be making an
open opening statement I'm going to wait
until I'm provoked by something someone
else says so let me introduce the fourth
panelist who will each make opening
remarks of five to seven minutes and
then and then we'll then I think we'll
proceed by having a little discussion up
here which I'll try to moderate and
direct questions and engage the
panelists with one another and then
we'll open up to questions and comments
from the floor there's really a lot to
talk about this is an unprecedented
crisis for well not unprecedented US
history but in the lifespan of pretty
much everyone in this room it is
certainly a one-of-a-kind event um bill
nor houses sterling professor of
economics will lead off the conversation
and talking about the broad
macroeconomic picture the diagnosis and
maybe he'll maybe he'll venture a little
bit of a prescription as well um Bob
Shiller the Arthur Okun professor of
economics will will talk two aspects of
be of behavioral economics and how they
reflect upon this macro economic crisis
and how those issues are recognizing
those issues are part of the solution
john gene accomplice the james tobin
professor of economics will talk about
more about the financial markets and how
they were in part the cause of the
crisis and how and how they might be
used to to solve the
the current situation and John Macey who
is an expert on banking regulation among
other things will talk about reform
that's needed in the financial sector
and offer a few more observations about
the politics of the current of the
current crisis so those are the that's
that that's basically the format for the
opening statements I think will range
all over the place this crisis obviously
has many components it's got the
problems in the housing sector where it
started it's got the problems in the
banking sector where it's spread to and
practically brought down it now has a
broad crisis of confidence and a kind of
freezing up of credit throughout the
economy and major macroeconomic
implications in terms of a rising
unemployment rate so there are a lot of
issues and a broad range of policy
instruments potentially available to
address them and I'm sure we will go all
over the map in the course of this
conversation so let's start out with
Bill Nordhaus
good evening where are we and what
should we do I'm going to talk about
where we are in this in these opening
remarks and then maybe we turn to the
other half of it these are central
issues where we are for the incoming
Obama administration they are required
to clean up the mess left by years of
private greed and public and DIF and
what I like to do is mention where we
are and what the particular features of
this business cycle the unique features
are there's little doubt we've entered a
long and deep recession every recession
is different they're like hurricanes
they in terms of severity duration
breath and the sectors they hit one way
of measuring the size of a recession is
the fraction of a year's income that is
lost the general estimates consensus
estimates is it will lose between 20 and
25 percent of one year's output national
income over the next four or five years
this is a severe recession it's about
equal to the deepest recession of the
post-war period which was the deep
recession from 1980 to 1984 although
it's much smaller than the Great
Depression CBO has estimated and other
private forecasters have estimated that
the stimulus plan will cut this gap by
about a quarter maybe a little more they
may be a little optimistic in their
forecasts but roughly speaking the
stimulus is handled about a quarter of
our problem now what I'd like to do is
talk about some of the the very
important different features of this
cycle I won't start it all began as the
president said with housing we talked
about that many times and you've heard
about it so I won't talk about it it was
a very unusual bubble Bob Shiller has
written about it we've come back a fair
amount toward the trend but we still got
a ways to go
the first interesting and important
feature is that partly because of
housing and partly because of other
markets more visible markets households
have taken a tremendous hit to their
wealth I don't have to tell most of you
that but in terms of peak to trough the
household net where wealth is down about
18 trillion dollars now whatever that
number means in terms of the average
household the average household wealth
is a down a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars per household in the United
States we might add some of the
government debt to that it is the
largest and rapid us fall on record in
the United States in terms of how fast
and how far it fell in this basically
year and a half period a second unusual
feature is our banks our banks look as
if they're bankrupt we don't know for
sure and indeed it's extremely difficult
to know given the complexity of bank
accounting but from what I do know and
gather the bank's if you sum up all the
networks after we do our stress test if
you sum up all the net words of the bank
that'll probably in the order of about a
trillion dollars the Obama
administration has set aside about a
tenth of that to recapitalize the banks
that's totally not enough and how we're
going to get the rest of it and how big
it is I just don't know but we cannot
get the banking system back to a
functioning basis until we get the
bank's recapitalized and get the federal
government out of their management a
third new it is area is a central part
of the modern financial system is asset
based finance particularly residential
mortgages but also consumers and realist
commercial real estate as well
this is severely wounded this whole
system the problem is a different one
from the banking system because
we don't know how we're going to get
that system going again whether it's
going to be replaced and if so how but
it's a very badly wounded part of a
financial system sixth you're counting
and unique since the 1930s is that the
traditional monetary policy is out of
business
as we put it in macroeconomics the
monetary policy is in a liquidity trap
and the central bank has run out of
ammunition
this is because when short run interest
rates get to zero there's no place
further to reduce them now it is true
the central bank can do other things it
can buy long-term securities it can try
to reduce spreads but those are much
more difficult and much more
controversial and as the Fed balance if
that does more of these its balance
sheet takes on more junk it's really
taken on fiscal tasks and it's making
central bankers very nervous final point
is that fiscal fatigue is setting in our
budget deficit for the current fiscal
year is projected to be two trillion
dollars this is about fourteen percent
of GDP and it's by far the largest ratio
in peacetime US history
outside of Wars and we're talking about
shooting Wars like World War two the
largest one was five percent so it's
almost three times larger than the last
the runner up now even people who are
usually relaxed about debts and deficit
are getting nervous about its size and
the problem is that if we need another
dose of fiscal stimulus as I think we
surely will and if we need another tarp
to capitalize the banking system as I
think we surely will then there's going
to be increasing resistance among
economists citizens
policymakers members of Congress and at
some point people may say I'd rather
just take my chances and let the economy
do it
rather than run larger deficits and
given everything that's going on we're
going to need to do more so I think you
get the picture we can come back to
remedies later but what I've tried to
suggest is that we do have these very
unusual features that are actually very
challenging for economic policy today so
I've been rather shocked at the change
in our level of economic confidence and
confidence in our system lately I was
recently at the World Economic Forum and
there was a session that Maria Bartiromo
had in which world leaders from all over
the world were asked to express their
opinions about the current crisis and I
was kind of shocked it seemed to be
unanimous that this crisis was
challenging our economic system that we
will never go back to the old framework
I didn't find anybody who stood up for
some of our old concepts of efficient
markets let the markets function I stood
up and said the Hat because nobody else
nobody else was saying it either there's
a number of examples Alan Greenspan in
recent testimony said the whole
intellectual edifice of modern risk
management has collapsed I was so I read
an article by kevin rudd who is the
Prime Minister of Australia and I'll
quote him from time to time in human
history there occur events of truly
seismic significance events that mark a
turning point between one epic and the
next when one orthodoxy is overthrown
and another takes its place and he went
on to say that our market
as it has function is really gone or has
to be replaced with something else so it
sounds a little worse than Bill Nordhaus
this is a bad recession from I'm talking
about how other people are reacting to
it
a recent the University of Michigan
Reuters poll asked Americans whether
about 2/3 of Americans said that they
think that the current crisis will last
at least five years so we are actually
fearing the Great Depression and the
bill says we're not there but Americans
I think it was another poll 30% of
Americans think that we're in a great
depression right now and the interesting
thing is that it seems like an event
like that is a self-fulfilling prophecy
of sorts you remember the in first
inaugural inaugural address of Franklin
Delano Roosevelt who said the only thing
to fear is fear itself but that's
exactly what we have now economists
Roger a farmer wrote a book called the
economics of self-fulfilling prophecies
and we used it as a textbook here for
our graduate students once but he didn't
have a theory about what creates these
self-fulfilling prophecy if everybody
thinks were in a depression they might
all contract their spending and they
might stop hiring and stop planning to
expand their businesses but he didn't
have an answer as to when that happens
or why that happens and so that's the
concern anyway I've written a book about
this which with my co-author George
Akerlof at University of California at
Berkeley and the book is entitled animal
spirits how the how psychology drives
the economy and why it matters for
global capitalism and the theme of our
animal spirits is a term that John
Maynard
Cheng's popularized and it refers to the
inconstant element of human nature that
people change their thinking and this is
what is so striking right now it seems
like in in the last couple of months
I sense a change in people's thinking I
talked to taxi drivers and I listen to
them and I just recently had a panicked
taxi driver I almost felt like I had to
hold his hand because he was so nervous
about and he thought he was going to be
wiped out by this crisis so that's where
we are so anyway I I've written two
books and he given me five minutes which
I've already exceeded I think but let me
just think say that Bill Nordhaus
pointed out the difficult situation
we're in and I agree with Bill that that
we need to in order to deal with this
problem we need a stronger fiscal
stimulus and we need a better
capitalisation of banks or better
policies to get credit going but I also
and that's that's one thing that George
Akerlof and I emphasize in our book but
I also think that and this is I think
equally important and not emphasized
enough that reacting to a crisis that
has people so panicked we have to think
about concerete constructing the system
creatively well that's what a lot of
people are asking for but we have to be
inventive about doing that
and in my other book subprime solution I
gave three main areas where I think
inventiveness should be developed
further one is in improving the
information infrastructure of the
economy and such things as improving
financial advice consumer protection
better disclosure and better economic
units of measurement I was just inspired
that one foreign country has I just got
a letter from someone saying that they
were thinking about one of my proposals
to
create a better indexation system
article indexed units of account and it
reminded me that we really have a very
flawed system reminded me of what
herbing fisher professor irving fisher
at yale in the first half of this
century he said a big part of the
problem of the depression was a debt
deflation problem that people have
nominal debts and deflation magnifies
them so I think we could fix that sort
of thing for the future by better
indexation schemes secondly I think we
need to improve our financial markets
make them work better not punish them
not shut them down not try to outlaw
derivatives but try to make the risk
management better and so this crisis was
substantially due to real estate risk
management failure and so that's one
example of the kind of risk management
that we should try to get going better
and finally we need I think improved
retail products that would help
consumers better things like home equity
insurance or what I call continuous
workout mortgages that would protect
homeowners from the kind of market
fluctuations that have hit them so
homeowners are in default now and often
because the market has made a move and
it's not their fault and they know that
so we need to have a system put in place
to prevent that so just to sum up I
think that we have not only short-run
problems but we have long-run problems
and to get confidence back we have to
start thinking about how we're moving to
a new and better world and thinking
about how to do that take some creative
invention some financial engineering and
finally the the purpose of all this is
to make our economic system work for the
people we have to democratize our
financial system and make sure that the
risk management is actually helping
everyone you
[Applause]
let me start by the way by thanking the
Yale College Council they put this
debate on last time and jonno introduced
us and I didn't get a chance to say what
I'm about to say now 20 years ago his
he's sitting right here in the second
row 20 years ago his father was a
brilliant PhD student here who wrote his
dissertation with me and I'm happy to
see his son now back at Yale from Maria
as a equally brilliant student named
John and so thank you for inviting me
and putting this all on now I have a I
think the problem is not that
complicated there's a very definite
cause of it and a very definite way of
attacking it by getting straight at the
cause we've deserted a lead for two
years two years ago we should have known
this was happening and started to deal
with it then had we done it the problem
would have gotten that bad there's still
a chance to do something about it the
problem is that the Fed should be
managing leverage and not just managing
interest rates so Shakespeare understood
this 400 years ago as I said last time
in the Merchant of Venice the most
famous negotiation ever appearing in
literature they negotiate [ __ ] alone
to Antonio and negotiate the interest
rate but they also negotiate the
collateral or the leverage now
Shakespeare obviously thought the
leverage was much more important than
the interest rate who can remember the
interest rate after all everybody
remembers the pound of flesh collateral
so collateral when you get a house you
put $20 down you buy a tea that means
$20 of cash allows you to buy $100 asset
your 500 to 25 times leveraged that's
what I'm talking about so in standard
traditional economics supply and demand
determines the interest rate one
equation one rate that's mostly the most
important variable in the economy
everybody talks about it all the time
the feds already supposed to do
something about it actually at this
debate my colleagues were still talking
about it I'm glad
that now we see that the interest rate
is not the problem is dived it's already
gone down to zero you can't make it any
lower but even four months ago or one
year ago if the interest rate wasn't the
heart of the problem it was the leverage
so variation and leverage makes a
tremendous difference to asset prices
why is that because all buyers aren't
alike the buyers have assets some of
them are more natural buyers more
inclined to buy it for various reasons
they're more sophisticated less more
risk tolerant more optimistic whatever
they're more natural buyers than the
others if the natural buyers can get
their hands on more money by borrowing
more with their $100.00 house they can
borrow about ninety instead of eighty
they'll spend the money buying more
assets and so the asset prices will go
up so going the wrong direction here
forward not backwards okay so so the
leverage cycle what is the leverage
cycle in normal or a billion times
there's too much leverage too high asset
prices in bad times on certain times
there's too little leverage too low
asset prices leverage dramatically
increased in 2006 on the on the subprime
that the subprime mortgages and other
so-called toxic mortgages there were 2.5
trillion of those toxic mortgages the
average mortgage was leveraged 16 to 1
that means a hundred fifty billion
dollars bought all of the 2.5 trillion
of orga jiz because the other 2.35
Chilean was borrow - people need Bill
Gates and and Warren Buffett alone could
have bought every single toxic mortgage
in the entire world just by putting
their own cash down and borrowing the
rest of it
no wonder the prices got so high it only
takes a few wildly optimistic people to
push the prices that high when they're
able to borrow so much money recently
leverage has crashed
those same toxic mortgage securities
their price is much lower but as a
percentage of they're now much lower
price you can only leverage them you can
only borrow you know less than half the
money they leverage one-and-a-half to
one or two to one sometimes you can't
borrow at all homes used to be able to
put 5% down in 2006 that was 20 to 1
leverage now you can put you have to put
down 20% if you can get a government
loan
he's even more so leverage is crashed
this leverage cycle has happened over
and over again this isn't the first one
here's a history of lever of haircuts
anyway so leverage leverage has an
important effect on the real world this
is I'm the James Dome professor this is
what I love to say this this is James
Tobin's idea Q if the financial system
collapses all financial isms a severe e
low prices that means by buying them you
can get very high returns the prices are
so low probably if you wait long enough
you'll get a high return why should
anyone do anything new why should anyone
give a new mortgage to someone why
should anyone buy and you'll set up a
new company they can invest it an old
company half the price it was a year ago
or our loan to an old mortgage or of 55
cents on the dollar why give a new guy
hundred two dollars when you can do
fifty five dollars on the same quality
loan of an old guys okay so this is
story of the leverage cycle it's a story
of rational agents they you know it's
rational when times are certain to have
a lot of leverage from the individuals
point of view it's rational when people
get nervous to demand little leverage a
lot of collateral individual rationality
but social disaster that's why it has to
be managed by the Fed Shakespeare knew
this to be the end of the merchants of
Venice is the the Regulatory Authority
sweeps in doesn't change the interest
rate doesn't change the amount of the
loan just changes the collateral says
it's not a pound of flesh
it's a pound of flesh but not a drop of
blood so what should we do today well
every leverage cycle ends exactly the
same way all these historical leverage
cycles they end with three things
happening some piece of something scary
and uncertain something bad happens that
creates more uncertainty that
uncertainty is what causes the lenders
to raise the margins and demand more
collateral the margins tighten leverage
plummets people have to fork have to
deal Everage sales or forced prices fall
and many of the optimistic buyers go
bankrupt so to get out of the problem
you have to deal with the three symptoms
you have to deal with the bad news which
is foreclosures and housing prices you
have two real everage the system and you
have to put more cash into the bank club
players that going to keep going like
the banks so just one word on each how
do you stabilize housing hopefully up
time too
talk with us later you have to take the
housing foreclosure decision out of the
servicers hands they're totally screwing
it up I hope in the question period I
can explain why and and what you need to
do in order to get homeowners to pay
again lowering the interest by one
percent or two percent that's why I
believe what they're going to propose
tomorrow that's not going to do it you
have to write down the principle so
here's a picture of who who actually is
defaulting on their homes if you look at
this graph it's for each different kind
of mortgage the top one is subprime
mortgages and you see at the bottom
that's the loan to value the current
combined loan-to-value so 60% means the
loan is the houses worth a hundred the
number below is how much the loan is the
loans only worth sixteen your house is
worth hundred everybody pays if the loan
is you know the loan the house has
fallen in value so the loan is now a
hundred sixty times the house every
month nine percent of the people are
defaulting that's every month it's not
unemployment that's causing them to
default nine percent of people don't go
unemployed every month every month nine
percent more people start to default why
because the house is only worth half as
much as their loan why pay a hundred why
pay a hundred dollars on a house that's
worth fifty okay so we'll come back to
that I hope the second thing the the
collapse and leverage the the crunch of
margins being tightened the Fed has to
reel Everage the system I can't just
give money to banks and hope that the
banks are going to turn around at more
generous collateral they're nervous they
have a right to be nervous it's scary
times the banks are going to ask for too
much collateral no one will be able to
borrow much money the Fed has to go
directly around the banks and directly
lend to the people are willing to borrow
and spend and then last year lastly the
Fed and the Treasury have to put more
money into the bank roll player now what
does that mean it's going to be a lot
more money than they've admitted these
banks like Citibank that has two
trillion of assets and two trillion of
debt you know and somehow they're just
barely balancing and they're not
balanced they're obviously hundreds of
billions of dollars short all these
banks are in deep trouble okay so we
have to face up to that it's going to
cost us hundreds and hundreds of
billions if not trillions of dollars
we're not going to rescue them that way
we're going to have to
like that they're going to default on
some of their loans we have to start
thinking about which loans can they
default on who can carry the bag outside
from the government okay we can talk
more about this way
[Applause]
so it's great to be back once again in
this forum thank you
John for inviting me again as a
securities professor eyelid vote the
privilege of depression and just
incorporate by reference my previous
comments from the last meeting and then
move on to make three quick points
within my five minutes about where we
are in the current crisis the first is a
is of is a is a plea to us as citizens
about how we should be in our private
lives as citizens kind of confronting
this problem a second is to kind of give
you a window on an unexplored problem
associated with this crisis which is the
kind of disjuncture between the economic
the the best practices economists have
for approaching this crisis and the kind
of legal and regulatory structure in the
financial industry that actually exists
and then the third thing so that you
won't go home disappointed I'll explain
how this problem can easily be solved
the financial problem so first the the
the major point really that I hope to
convince you of is that there's
something fundamentally wrong not with
what is being said about the financial
crisis by our leaders but rather with
how it's being said that is to say that
the political discourse associated with
the economic crisis the bailout bill the
recent stimulus plan that was signed
into law earlier this afternoon has been
fundamentally anti-democratic in that
whether you agree with it or disagree
with I think it's been anti-democratic
in that all sides are taking the sort of
professional kind of if you will elitist
position that says this is not you kind
of average people don't really
understand this we're in really big
trouble here's the way to solve it
the Paulson said this
Geithner said this the world will end
and particularly at a university like
this we ought to be able to expect our
leaders and hold our leaders to a
standard that they should be able to
articulate to us and some kind of
coherent fashion exactly why it is that
it's necessary for example to mention
one of my favorite provisions from the
stimulus plan to build this light rail
train from Las Vegas to Los Angeles and
how that's going to solve us save us
from financial oblivion and many other
many other aspects like that so
basically the ideas I think would be
better to have a tattoo - to take the
view that that this is that we should
try and resist the tyranny of the
experts and try to demand from our
leaders not a financial plan or stimulus
package or a ballot bill that we agree
with but at least is is presented in a
in an articulate way such that normal
sort of democratic processes can be used
because I think this this kind of
tyranny of experts is fundamentally
anti-democratic now the second point I
want to make is that for this is the
sort of quasi technical point is that
there has been a certain Regulus
regulatory structure in place not in
just in the US but in the world with
respect to financial institutions and
that we have fundamentally abandoned
that that that regulatory structure and
it's not at all we're going to have to
erect an entirely new regulatory
structure moving forward and that's
going to be a very good job and they're
very big job and here's basically what I
what I mean about that generally
speaking the financial institutions the
financial structure of economies in
developed countries all over the world
have been constructed into kind of
analytically we can think of them as
concentric circles in the middle of the
concentric circle is the commercial bank
the old-fashioned
horsewhipping buddy buggy financial
institution that essentially took
transaction accounts deposits and made
commercial loans and then building out
from that and in the structure of the
regulatory system was to reduce the risk
associated with those financial
institutions as much as possible and
then moving out and out from that would
be institutions that would be able to
accept more risk like investment banks
hedge funds private equity firms
insurance companies all sorts of other
firms in the economy and the idea has
been among central bankers who are
involved not all of them are but they
are in the US central bankers who are
involved in financial policy the ideas
that that these other the other
financial institutions in the economy
should be a source of strength for
commercial banks because that's really
if you sort of think about a triage
that's really where the aspect of the
economy we have to protect it's where
people's people's basic savings are or
should be where people's keep their
their money and where we have
transactions occur that have to occur
for the economy to move on we've moved
to exactly opted the opposite of that
model we now have under with
particularly with the move of Goldman
Sachs and Morgan Stanley to to the
banking model and some relaxation of
some regulations we can talk about our
model is now clearly the inverse of what
it it used to be now the notion is that
our commercial banks the goldman sachs
bank now the morgan stanley bank should
be a source of strength for all of the
other financial institutions in the
economy and it's not at all this is a
very bold new step and it's not at all
clear that this new model of kind of
financial regulation will work it'll be
extremely interesting in my view to look
over the next several years see how this
works out finally in my last thing i
told you i would solve this crisis so
what do we need to do to solve this to
solve this crisis well you know we need
some mechanism for generating wealth and
discomfort in this country for
increasing demand at a time when people
are saving
a lot for bringing in a spirit of
entrepreneurs here to have
entrepreneurship to have lots and lots
of kind of loci of wealth creation if
you will in a way that's that's
consistent with us what I view is best
kind of us traditions we're not going to
do that by printing money my subject to
the the counsel of the economist
colleagues on the panel when I can do
this so how can we do it well the answer
is simple we do it the old-fashioned
American Way immigrant immigration that
is to say that the into my way of
thinking the only the only coherent
mechanism this we could talk about
monetary policy and fiscal policy but at
the end of the day we're going to have
we have you know five million empty
houses in this country growing at a very
quick rate and by by liberalizing what I
think was the the extremely strove early
strict recent immigration policy the
Bush administration and even prior to
that I think we would begin to see new
attitudes coming into the country new
entrepreneurial spirit and I jokingly
before this I call this the the Rick
Levin plan because I've just proposed to
him for the country with president xi is
proposing do two for Yale by building
the two new residential colleges but but
I think that it regardless of what your
view is on the residential colleges I
think they've done that we should we
should look at a liberalized immigration
policy as a cornerstone to addressing
this financial crisis
I thought I'd try to lead a little
discussion now among the panelists
before opening it up but first a couple
of observations you know those of you
who are Yale students which is most of
you you're going to have opportunities
as you as you move on into your careers
your we're trying to educate you for
leadership roles in society and so I
daresay many of you will have the
experience some time in your life of
moderating a panel and I want to point
out you here let me give you a practical
lesson in life if you tell an economist
to take five minutes he will take ten
that's why and and since ten was what I
wanted I told them five
had I told him 10 for sure they would
have taken 20 so it worked out perfectly
the lawyers are more obedient John you
were closer so just remember that
now it's those salary freezes Rick would
worry
I think listen III was I was I actually
shivered a little bit when I heard about
the executive compensation freeze
thinking - we - we take government money
here you know but of course my bonus is
zero so anyway if you think III think
that was a very stimulating set of
comments and in fact if the stimulus
package it had that much stimulus we
wouldn't be having to talk about all
this but but I do I do think that
there's there is a lot of internal
consistency in what you heard and I'll
just make one observation about that I
mean I think they or one sort of
connective thread I think that if you
begin with with john geanakoplos view
that that the fundamental problem that
caused this crisis was over leveraging
and there's ample evidence to support
that if you just to give a piece that he
didn't give the at the end of 2007 the
ratio of public and private debt to GDP
stood at three and a half to one the
high it had never been higher than two
and a half to one any previous business
cycle peak so it was way out of line I
mean out of line for a decade but it was
over two and a half to one for almost a
decade prior to the peak so the
regulators should have been alert to the
fact that there was an awful lot of
leverage in the economy it's the over
leveraging that permitted the the
housing bubble that Bob Shiller talks
about as the proximate cause of the
crisis it was it was the the you know
the subprime and indeed even some of the
not subprime mortgages that were that
allowed more that kept allowing more and
more leverage in into the housing
and spurred housing prices and they
eventually crashed as Dunn said they
would in such cases and you end up and
you end up with this vicious circle that
leads to the conditions that bill
Nordhaus described where where where you
start to have enormous losses in asset
values and wealth lending gets curtailed
spending gets curtailed and you're n
we're in the trouble we are now so I it
all it all coheres I think is a picture
the question becomes what to do I think
that there's some consensus there to at
least I hear you know implicitly I think
maybe the economic Spartan doesn't have
enough intellectual diversity but I
think I think the arguments that the
stimulus package itself only does a
fraction of what is needed is I would
agree with that I would also agree that
the recapitalisation of the banks is
needed and is so far been you know way
less than what is needed but um but but
I think you know let's let's get a
little let's get a little conversation
here by I'm an ass John gene accomplice
you you seem to think the fixing the
financial system is the main thing to do
but do what about macro policy and what
about fiscal stimulus is it necessary
can it will all get fixed by fixing the
financial system well once the solut
sorry let me put it this way the
financial system was the cause of our
problems once the problems start to
spread to the real economy they get
worse and worse and then maybe more
things are needed to do than just fix
the financial system but one of the
favored one of the things I'm always
like to point out is that prices
collapsed in subprime mortgages two
years ago one of the advantages of
having a market economy like we do and
having all these complicated assets as
you can see what maybe they're not
experts because they make mistakes but
the people who have their money at risk
are predicting is going to happen in the
economy and in the in the beginning of
2007 two years ago I have a graph to
show it there was a
I can show the graph it's quite
startling that this in in 2007 here's
the graph you see how prices have been
completely flat if you go to the
horizontal line if you can see that can
you see that back there all right you
can't see in the ground all right well
I'll tell you what's on it they're
totally flat from the left tab to the
right half there at a hundred no blip is
imaginable and then halfway through the
graph which is in January of 2007 the
prices suddenly collapsed these are of
subprime mortgage subprime mortgage
bonds they just collapsed now that means
nobody been thrown out of their houses
nothing had happened in the economy
there was you couldn't detect anything
wrong with the economy and the prices
completely collapsed that's because
people who looked at the data all the
time realized that something was
happening something awful was going to
happen we had two years to fix the
system two years we did nothing
absolutely nothing just from those
prices alone
you knew that the market was thinking
50% 70% of the five million subprime
homeowners are going to be thrown out
onto the streets they already knew that
in 2007 did we do anything about it
absolutely nothing so had we taken the
right steps two years ago to fix the
financial system wouldn't gotten into
the place to the place we are now so I
think that the financial system is the
key and that's what has to be fixed
first but I agree implicitly with your
question that you know now that problems
have spread so far we've got to do
something else I like a lot of the
things Obama's got in his fiscal plan we
should have been doing them a long time
ago you know so things that we should do
I'm in favor of doing having a bunch of
random tax cuts I'm not so in favor of
but you know if we could just move up
all those bridges we are going to build
ten years from now and do them all next
year that's the sort of thing I think we
should do the thing that was missed on
the fiscal stimulus still absent in the
package that doesn't make any sense to
me is why we have to think about
shovel-ready projects that haven't yet
started they're building a bridge across
the Quinnipiac River it's underway
they're pulling a bridge by the way on
Street okay why not double down on the
crews on the work crews on the projects
that are already underway why bother to
wait for new projects as will take time
part of the stimulus package is a fifty
four billion dollar two-year fiscal
stabilization policy for the states so
that's twenty seven billion per year but
the state of Connecticut is projecting a
deficit of between six billion and eight
point five billion so even if the state
is if we gave it all to the state of
Connecticut right it'd be alright but
there are 50 states this seems like one
case where the stimulus bill was
inadequate useful because states are
cutting back and all kinds of services
they're laying people off and we that
would be the place immediately that not
to stop dog the blood bill you well you
said you would tell us more about the
you know your remedies in which you you
of only alluded to well I don't have it
I don't have any I don't I had not
thought of immigration as a solution to
have dissipated and that's that's the
kind of that's the kind of thinking we
need to have today so I think I'll just
say three quick things on remedies one
is I do think the stimulus plan was
probably too small for what we needed
it was probably also stretched out too
long I actually not of the camp that
thinks we ought to have a have another
trillion dollars of Public Works because
I think it isn't front-loaded enough I
actually do think that something in the
order of either temporary or tax cuts or
ones that are say time limited is a much
more effective way of getting the
economy going over that time period
we're talking about that's pretty
straightforward stuff and we've actually
that's under the bridge at this point I
can't imagine would we open it until
next year I do think the financial
crisis the banking crisis and the more
general situation is much more
challenging
both politically and actually
analytically I think we're going to get
rather I don't quite know the thinking
of the administration but it seems as if
they are trying to go down and figure
out they do the stress test to get
people used to the idea that as I think
everybody said the banks are in trouble
when the stress comes out and we see the
banks that are in trouble so maybe we
see that rather than it being it being
confidential information then I think at
that point people are going to be very
shocked and because of the need to find
a whole nother set of funds to to take
care of the banks now one solution that
I think was in John implicit in what
John said was that we would we would
basically allow the equity holders of
the banks and all the bondholders of the
banks to lose all the value I actually
don't know what those numbers are total
up to but they're probably not pretty
sure they're not sufficient they're
maybe a fraction of the fraction of the
problem so I do think we're going to end
up with needing to take some of the
assets off the books of the banks I
think the government is going to have to
seize the banks seize them is that a
technical term for take them over take
the bad assets out because you can't
have bank with ambiguous valued assets
recapitalize them if they need it and
sell them off again I think that the
lesson of Japan which went through this
process for almost 20 years was that in
the end you're going to have to do this
the longer you wait the to do this the
longer it takes to build public
consensus that that's what needs to be
done the more you're just going to have
stagnation so I think this is really
going to be an active real sort of
grown-up nough 'some unghh our
politicians whether they can actually
face up to the fact that we're going to
have to put a lot of money to fix our
banking system I just mentioned one
other thing I've focused on the
commercial banks the commercial banks
are about one-fifth of the size of the
total US financial system eighty percent
of the liabilities of the natural system
are outside the
Marshall banks pension fund some of them
are pension funds which are different
American mutual funds mutual funds
pension funds insurance and so on
they're all hedge funds private equity I
think one of the things that is going to
have to happen and the people in those
sectors are not going to like is we're
going to have to spread the net of
regulation much broader and we're going
to if the levered and I agree with John
that we're going to have to put in
binding leverage constraints on a lot of
financial institutions but this is not
just banks this is going to be have to
be outside the banking system as well
and we're going to hear a lot of cries
of anguish from people who were not
regulated before and even didn't even
have to disclose their assets and their
ballot sheets
lots of cries of anguish about how this
is unnecessary unfair will wreck
capitalism and more tenders down the
road to serfdom but I think that's
actually what one of the steps we're
going to have to take in addition to
recapitalization John any lessons from
banking regulation I mean you know that
history and so there's I think that
there is a huge lesson from banking
regulation it relates very closely to
what Bill is just talking about so we
have and I think you'll hear this word
used a lot in the next few weeks if you
haven't heard it already
we are landscape is being taken over by
the what are known as zombie financial
institutions I don't know if you're
familiar with that term but a zombie
financial institution isn't it is a
financial institution who whose
liabilities exceeds exceed its assets so
it's it's insolvent in a balance sheet
sense but it has enough cash to kind of
keep going for a while and financial
institutions are great at being zombies
because to the extent that they can
borrow money from the government in
through the discount window or accept
federally insured deposits they can keep
attractive cash for a very long time so
the the the big lesson in history with
respect to dealing with the problem that
we're basically confronted with which is
the zombie
a bank is what is known in bank
regulatory circles as prompt corrective
action prompt intervention and the
reason for that is imagine it you know
IO in a financial institution that's a
zombie right so the equity has been
wiped out the liabilities exceed the
assets if I have some cash so what do I
do I take the cash and I go to no
Mohegan Sun and I put all the money on
odd at the roulette wheel or whatever
they have in between each 27 and you
know if from the standpoint of the
owners of this financial institution if
I lose as I'm likely to do I'm no worse
off than I was well all the all the risk
is being shouldered by the fixed
claimants by the depositors in our case
that the government of course in the off
chance that you know the number that I
choose comes up then you know I've made
my bonanza and we've been restore the
assets increase in value we've been
restored to solvency so this is you know
classic moral hazard problem but it's
it's it's accentuated in the context of
regulated financial institutions that
have such easy access to debt and
government-sponsored credit enhancements
on that debt and the basic lesson of
banking regulation not just in the US
but in many other countries that have
had financial crises Japan being one
Swede in the Czech Republic Israel went
through this is you have to move very
quickly to get the management of these
financial institutions into the hands of
people whose incentives are line aligned
with the people who are the real owners
the real stakeholders in the bank and it
really bothers me frankly and and upsets
me as a taxpayer that you know we've
done so little in the financial
resolution in the addressing this
financial crisis in getting rid of the
incumbent boards of directors and
management teams and this financial
institutions not because they make so
much money I don't you know it's rather
because of this moral hazard that I just
described and and so I think that that
we need to move quickly to clear these
those debts Bob yeah I just really
important point
was just made which is banks that are
kazaaam be banks the banks of the close
to the line are dangerous they're very
dangerous because you're in the
situation where they can take risks and
if they win they're alive and if they
lose other they did buy the taxpayer has
to take a moment all right so they were
actually - it's one of the lessons is
when bad bank when good banks go bad
they become dangerous and I think that
was a very important point that I think
has actually not been made in the pocket
in the public discourse on this but
technically the Japanese banks were
Dombey banks for a long time and they
didn't really go crazy taking risks the
way your suggestion because it was so
bad they had no chance again one more
question we'll open it up Bob I just
want to come back to the housing market
and you I know you have a lot of
prescriptions but do you but I mean
among most of your prescriptions are
looking to the long term how to prevent
another asset bubble of the type that
occurred how about in terms of getting
us out of trouble I mean would you agree
with John that we that we ought to be
writing down the value of outstanding
housing debt yeah I agree with John Paul
heartedly right I had a in my book
subprime solution I had a less well
formulated version I said we should
restart the homeowners Loan Corporation
that was created in 1933 and which
bailed out about 20% of US mortgages and
so that's what you want to do is say
like that and and apparently what we'll
hear tomorrow from the president based
on news speculation is that he will be
subsidizing a lower mortgage rate and
that doesn't solve the problem so we'll
see I think this is a big issue that
we're foreclosing people and throwing
them out of their houses and I think
this generates bad feeling and this is
part of the sense of confidence that we
have in our economy that we feel fairly
treated these people are not being
fairly treated now some people would say
we ought to teach them a lesson that
they have to pay their
debts but I think that people will learn
the wrong lesson if they are foreclosed
and thrown out of their house but don't
you think I mean there is John was
saying there is a difference between
lowering the interest rate I mean
technically both both lowering the
interest rate writing down the mortgage
lower the present value of payments that
people have to make but but over over
the life of the asset but whether of
their obligation but that but writing
down the value of the mortgage actually
leaves people with positive equity which
has which has some different behavioral
implications right when you would not
want to do that preferably though yeah
and so what I think is that we should be
systematic about doing that incidentally
we shouldn't be just doing it as an
emergency we should this reminds me of
the homeowners Loan Corporation again at
the same time that they created the holc
they also generated new and better
mortgage institutions so this shouldn't
be a one-time only thing we should be
thinking about making a systemic very
good what else good can I just order
that so I don't know whether John was
being a little tongue-in-cheek about you
know filling up all these foreclosed
houses with immigrants but you know I
think that we have to the people are in
the houses should stay in the houses we
shouldn't just throw them all out and
put immigrants in their houses so so
thank you for that correction so the the
reason they're being thrown out is
because this it's a it's a collective
action problem the servicers who are in
charge of rewriting the mortgages just
can't do it and so it helps nobody to
throw these people out of their houses
but the public doesn't realize is the
the market in those pictures I showed
you forecast that the typical subprime
person when he's thrown out of his house
you'll get 25 cents on the dollar back
by reselling the house it's incredibly
expensive to throw someone out of their
house it takes a year and a half they
trashed the house they don't pay for
year and a half they don't pay taxes for
your and a half you have to hire a real
estate agent to resell it incredible
number of expenses 25 cents and the
dollars what's expected throwing people
out of their houses helps not the people
and it doesn't help the bondholders
either so the the more
you just have to be reworked the only
way I believe and that's what Bob saying
to to get the people to pay is to make
it so that the house you know which may
be worth fifty or sixty now is more than
a loan if the houses were sixteen the
loans down to fifty these people have
something to fight for they know if they
can make their payments and scrape by
for a few years they can sell the house
and get more money make a profit you see
if you lower the interest the guy knows
it's not his house no matter when he
sells it the loans going to be more than
the value of the house you lower the
interest rate by two percent when the
loan is 100 the house is worth fifty
that means it's not your house and
they'll treat it like it's not their
house the only way to make it their
house again is to lower the loan below
the the principal and you can say just
as Bob said also terrible those people
they've cheated the system they're
scoundrels let's screw them okay but
you're screwing we're screwing ourselves
by trying to screw them it's not to help
them so much although that's important
it's to help everybody that we don't
throw them out of their houses
maybe we'll open up for some questions
from the floor there are microphones at
the front of each aisle and you can
direct them at one particular panelist
if you would my question is for
professor Macy following up on that
discussion on the servicers needing to
me to get these servicers to lower the
principal we need to to change the value
of these mortgages that's the only
solution we've all seemed on the panel
every seems to agree with that so my
question for you professor Macy and we
came from an earlier talk today that you
and I both attended how do you make that
happen legally how do we make that
happen these asset holders the people
that hold these securities can they
litigate to prevent that can they
litigate to prevent the service the
servicers from changing the principle
right okay so it that's a great question
the the critical term that I think John
used a moment ago was a collective
action problem and if I could hear
basically the problem is this it's
fascinating really if you think about it
imagine someone's in the Hat and a house
and their mortgage payment is fifteen
hundred dollars a month and the person
cannot afford to pay that anymore
imagine that if there's foreclosure etc
the the the person who holds that
mortgage will receive
200 dollars a month in the future both
parties would be better off by reaching
some kind of accommodation where some
amount greater than 200 and less than
1400 say 800 would would be paid and
allow the person to stay in their house
and one of the most staggering things
from a legal perspective and kind of
from ilanic and I was perspective about
the current crisis is that most
economists and I think you're absolutely
correct look around the economy and they
see millions and millions of these
potentially jointly wealth maximizing
deals contracts that could be made
between people and houses and and and
the owners of the ultimate payments
during the owners of the of the
mortgages to work out a you know a deal
to a contract a contract abridgement
that would make both parties better off
and it's stunning that there appear to
be kind of legal obstacles to making
this work I think that the the solution
is pretty simple which is there are sort
of technical rules in the Bankruptcy
Code which make it very difficult for
bankruptcy judges to reach this middle
ground in a in it and to a change the
change the amount of money that that
that people in houses get to pay also
it's much easier to just odd historical
reasons to rewrite non mortgage
contracts so my legal solution would be
and there probably are others that are
that it would work as well or maybe
better but is - is to change the
Bankruptcy Code to allow the changes in
these mortgage contracts such that you
could you could do exactly what John was
and and and and and Bob were suggesting
I think that of lowering the amount of
money that people people pay and and
this would make the creditors better off
as as well as the as the debtors
since everyone seems to agree with this
idea I want I would like to say that I'm
skeptical as John knows I think the
housing mortgage problem is one that
needs a wholesale solution and I think
this is retail I'll just give one
example why I think it's much too
complex there are many too many
mortgages and John well John we'll have
to talk for the length of the Great
Depression before he actually persuades
enough people that this is going to be
written into law gets written into law
and actually gets undertaken the federal
government did something which was a
similar thing passed a law last fall
they did the first at the 90-day review
they reviewed how many mortgages had
been rewritten under the federal law and
as of that time there were 13 contracts
had been entered into and zero had
actually been rewritten and I think the
problem with problem with trying to
reform the servicers and all these tens
of millions of badeley out of whack
coordination problems is it simply won't
get done and unless this is a
decade-long problem it won't get done on
the time scale that we needed to get
done and meanwhile housing prices are
falling 2% per month if they keep going
at 2% per month
according to the Case Shiller index if
they keep falling at that then by the
time we that we've had two years
according to John already people still
haven't figured it out
another two years housing prices will be
down another 25 percent and presumably
at that point we will solve the problem
not through fixing the servicer problem
but basically because the housing bubble
will come to an end and housing prices
will stop falling I think there may be
some issues some some more wholesale
ways of doing it and I actually think a
combination of interest rate relief and
even radical ideas like tax credits for
mortgage payments are much likely to get
to more people than trying to reform the
Bankruptcy Code there's an obvious macro
solution though which is the use the
case-shiller index and just write down
all the mortgages by the decline in
housing values I mean there's a simple
you know kind of Occam's razor macro
solution to use
could I make a comment so you know um I
have enormous respect for my colleague
bill and for his judgement about what
political it's not political but I think
he raises an interesting point here why
is it that for two years nobody did
anything about this problem now clear
that the private sector wasn't going to
solve the problem because the servicers
had a conflict of interest their
interest the servicers are the people
who are delegated the authority to
handle the loans by the bondholders who
own them the servicers don't generally
own any of the cash flows so they're not
getting the money by doing something
better and improving the loan and
getting more money they're not getting
any of it so they have no incentive to
go to a huge amount of trouble to change
everything around when they don't see
any the money it's incredibly expensive
they don't get anything for it and on
top of that they run the risk of getting
sued so it's obvious why for two years
they didn't solve the problem the
question is why didn't you know bill
Nordhaus and other great economists why
didn't they they why didn't they help
solve the problem why didn't why didn't
your Jewish and his administration start
to solve the problem I think bills put
his finger on part of it that it
requires a radical solution and people
you know are are hesitant to do radical
things but what I'm proposing okay so I
proposed that the government go out and
hire a bunch of bankers you know
community bankers to rework all these
loans they might have to hire several
thousand of them maybe ten thousand of
them okay but they're they're bankers
all over the country with unemployed or
working at banks and would gladly take
these jobs it's not a problem to find
the manpower okay and the thing is this
could have been started two years ago it
could have been started four months ago
these principle you can't reduce the
principal of every house in the country
you know they're too many houses that's
too big a loss then you really kill the
bondholders we're talking about the
subprime many people in the know let's
take a typical middle-class family from
Peoria they're going to pay their
mortgage they'll they'll fight to the
end to pay their mortgage you know it's
their whole dignity their family moving
the schools being given up they're going
to pay their mortgage but the subprime
borrower people like that who are all
living
the edge already they're the ones who
make the calculation it's not worth it
to pay they're the ones whose need the
loan written down and to keep them in
the house and to keep them going I don't
think this is any harder to do than to
reduce the interest rate by a couple
percent you know it might take a few
more months but I think writing down the
interest rate a couple percents not
going to do anything you know Bush has
had 25 different policies if you've been
watching over the last year with the FHA
does this and someone else does that and
a few loans change here and there and
nothing gets solved it requires a
wholesale that was bills were at a
wholesale solution to the problem we
have to get on it and do something and
yes there's resistance whenever I say
this idea the government's to hire all
these guys to look at the loans and
write them down you know to the right
level some write it down to the guy you
can actually expect the guy to pay
there's no point in writing alone from
100 to 50 if you know the guy is not
even going to pay 50 so you have to look
at the people and look at what they have
it's a little bit different than just
using the Case Shiller index you have to
look at the homeowner see what the
housing values are then write it down so
it takes a little bit of trouble a
little few people you have to hire we've
got to do this on a grand scale if this
is the Great Depression we're between
one epic and another as Bob was saying
it's going to require a little bit of
effort on the government's part could I
add that in 1933 but I mentioned the
homeowners Loan Corporation and that
doing that involved they got 20% of all
mortgages refinanced and they looked at
them individually they hired people they
set up offices in every major city and
then people would go to the office and
they would apply and they would be
evaluated and their mortgage would be
adjusted it happened bankers rented out
for less than those days um okay another
question
the zombie institutions so um I am
wondering what you guys think of the
proposal of just letting them fall apart
as opposed to doing Lehman Brothers
again as opposed to taking over them
Allah
you know Swiss and not going to Japan
way taking them over recapitalizing and
fusing them and trying to make them
really good banks all over again why not
just alternatively let them fall apart
like Lehman I understand like now that
certain parts of Lehman are actually
quite valuable like their prime
brokerage and so if you let these really
big institutions fall apart but then get
bought out or they're profitable parts
of them get bought out why wouldn't that
be a less costly solution I mean is that
just going to wreak havoc all over the
place or might that be a way to go Gaja
say I think the worst single decision
that was made outside of the war in Iraq
over the last eight years was the
decision to let Lehman go bankrupt and
the reason when it's not that you
couldn't wind them up but the fact that
you basically broke all the links
somebody told me that Lehman had a
hundred thousand contracts and who knows
what happened to all those contracts so
what you need to do is the first thing
you said you need to basically take them
over in an orderly way you need to get a
structured procedure and we actually
have a structured procedure we do this
with banks all the time to take them
over and to take them apart to REE but
them back together but the idea of just
letting them go in the sense of the way
Lehman did is not going to work
what you had is if Lehman went at 12
o'clock at 12:01 you had thousands of
seizing collateral calling people up
calling the lawyers trying to figure out
what to do and you had a freezing up and
if you actually look I'm sorry we don't
have a little graph here of what
happened to all the risk spreads that
you can follow the risk spreads and what
happened is the system went haywire when
that was allowed to happen and you can
imagine if that
was allowed to happen for bank after
bank after financial institution and for
financial institution so I think we have
to go in and we have to clean them up
but that is I think that's a very
dangerous precedent to follow there
basically you can divide all the experts
on the financial crisis into two groups
one group are the people who say that
the biggest mistake we've ever making
make it made was allowing lehman
brothers to fail and the other group is
saying just about the only thing we've
done right in this crisis is to let
Lehman fail i think professor Nordhaus
though touched on something very
important which is it's the neither one
of those answers in my view and i think
this is consistent with his answer so I
may be wrong is is right and the way to
think about it is if you think about it
and again this gets back to the point I
was making earlier about this very
different regulatory structure we have
for banks versus non banking firms in
the US if you're a non banking firm and
you're insolvent like Lehman Brothers
was an investment bank not a bank they
filed they become bankrupt then they
filed under it with bankruptcy court for
protection under Chapter eleven usually
which is what Lehman Brothers did of the
of the Bankruptcy Code if you're a
commercial bank you're prohibited by
statute for filing for bankruptcy
protection and exactly it's professor
Nordhaus said you the government
regulators are required to come in and
quote resolve unquote the financial
institution oddly and unfortunately one
of the things that to my way of thinking
we've learned from this financial crisis
is that the alternative structure that
we have in place for banks resolving
failed banking institutions is is is
much much more efficient than the
bankruptcy process that Lehman Brothers
is subjected to so my view is yes I kind
of think you know in I disagree with
Ramon Ornelas I think we should have let
Lehman Brothers fail but I don't think
we should have let it fail the way that
it failed I think that we should have
allowed it to fail the way we allowed
Bear Stearns to fail or you know to
resolve it in the context of a managed
process is overseen by regulators now if
we listen to what's going on in
Washington the Pascal
Dasia we hear this famous word somebody
mentioned before this idea we're going
to go into banks and stress test banks
that's what they're saying they're
saying look we're going to other
institutions are going to fail because
you give people stress tests it's not
like yellow school some people actually
fail so the-- and those are the ones
that fail they're going to be resolved
some way hopefully not the way that
Lehman Brothers was resolved right but
hopefully in a more in a more organized
way so the next question there's been a
lot of talk recently about prioritizing
different parts of both the bailout of
the financial institutions as well as
the stimulus so I wanted to ask for
anyone on the panel who wanted to talk
about it if you were given 787 billion
dollars to do whatever in whatever order
you thought was necessary and two
regulations one or two regulations or
policies that you could undo or create
what would they be and in what order you
go through that process
what's the try that
stimulus not the tongue no no no he's
saying if you had 787 period right
stimulus and tarp it could be yeah
anything I'll let the priorities I'll
just say priority because you know if
we'd give our own list it'll take the
whole list we'll take too long so I
would real Everage the system so how
does how I think items going to announce
something like this and I think he's
going to probably announce I hope he
does the right thing well put it that
way so what as I said the problem was
that people used to be able to borrow 98
cents on a triple a security used to be
able to borrow 98 percent of the value
main gate point four percent of the
value for triple a security only had to
put 1.6 percent down in cash to buy it
so that's what kept the price so high
now you can borrow almost nothing even
on triple-a security so basically aren't
any triple-a securities left in the
mortgage world practically so you can't
borrow on them or you can borrow just a
little bit so what the Fed they're
talking Geithner's talking about
partnering with the private sector what
does he mean by that the government
can't go off and buy securities it
doesn't know how much to pay for them it
doesn't understand them you know would
have to hire an entire research
department and there even the research
guys sometimes don't know you need to
hire experienced traders and researchers
it's just a very complicated thing you
know they're definitely going to get
outsmarted by the people trying to sell
the stuff so what it's so I think they
are hopefully recognizing that so what I
would do is I would go directly to the
buyers whether they're hedge funds or
banks or whoever wants to buy these
securities these are the toxic things
the banks have on their balance sheets
that have such a low value because no
one can buy them anymore because they
can't borrow to get them I'd say if you
want to buy those securities will lend
you 50% or 60% of the value of the
security now the private sector won't
lend 50 or 60 or 70% of the value of the
security because they're too scared they
might lose money so the private sector
is not crazy there must be a risk that
they will lose money so the Fed the
government is going to be running a risk
doing that and so you have to set so
part of the money I would set aside in
case they lose a little money on that
but if you lend 60 percent against $100
security the security goes down 40% in
value
you lose nothing as the federal
government though the private sector who
bought it loses that 40% if the
government buys directly and it goes
down 40% the taxpayer loses 40% so you
have this huge 40% cushion and so I
would partner with the private private
industry by getting the private sector
to buy but help fuel that buying by
making government loans at more generous
collateral terms and the private sector
is willing to do which of course means
running a risk and you have to set aside
money to cover that risk I believe that
once they get that going
doctor pump in a lot a lot of money you
know hundreds of billions maybe a
trillion dollar of loan something like
that they'll that they'll start to raise
a lot of these security prices and some
of the banks balance sheets won't look
as bad and and it won't be so easy to
invest in old securities people do know
things so that was the one thing right
John John's illustrating a point that's
worth keeping in mind that you just
don't Detroit if you read the press you
would never understand and that is that
the money that's been used for the
financial system is actually a different
it's not commensurate with the stimulus
money assumed as money is direct
spending that is going to add to a
national deficit so far something like
buying preferred shares and banks or
taking partnerships in in supporting
loan and you know giving loans to the
private sector to buy assets these are
investments the government's making
they're not actually they're not going
to necessarily have it they have the
prospect of earning a return I mean if
in fact weak recapitalize the banks
leaving aside john scheme going to
something more like like what we did
with tarp 1 if and take deferred shares
and my recapitalizing the banks that a
6% I mean if we're right we get a 6%
return on the public money and the banks
are recapitalized so it's not it's you
can't really add them up the money is
it's a different type of government
transaction I want to I want answer the
question directly I think that the
central issue we face is that we have to
get the economy back toward full
employment
until we do that all these problems are
going to be with us they may not be with
us the same way but if you have a highly
depressed economy with it with
corporations basically living on the
edge of bankruptcy the car companies
can't sell enough cars and so and so
forth
you're going to profits down you can
have highly leveraged institutions in
trouble that's not just the banking
system but the other highly leveraged
institutions profits go way down in deep
recessions and when profits go down
securities markets are in trouble so I
think I think the key thing not I think
we have two hands so we can do two
things at once but if you only had one
hand I think what I do with the one hand
is focused primarily on trying to get
the economy back to full employment but
I think we can do both but I think
that's unless you do that you're going
to have trouble all across upon having
the stimulus package it would be all
stimulus be now whether it's stimulus or
whatever there lots of ways to do it and
fixing the financial system helps do
that but I don't think if you fix the
van axle system in the middle of a
depression it's not going to it's not
going to bring you back to it's not
going to stimulate the economy by the
way you gave us a problem of investing
of using only 787 billion it reminds me
that this is a world problem and it's
just too small a number to work with
this the world economy is something like
closer to a hundred trillion so it's
just it's nowhere near enough actually
but but you're right but it's good to
focus the priority yeah I would just
like to follow up a little bit more on
the problem of the the illiquid
mortgage-backed securities that a lot of
financial institutions are holding just
in respect to the fact that they're
holding the securities and everything a
lot of the problems seems to be that no
one knows the value of those securities
and that what my understanding is a lot
of these Institute server
Selvam because of the losses they'll be
forced to take and how we can reel
Everage the system when we don't know
the value of the assets the banks are
holding if we're forced to sell them of
course and I know part of that has to do
with a lot of people asking for an end
to mark-to-market regulations but I
don't know for president rank op is
probably a six okay what your question
really combines two problems one is the
the problem of the banks and whether
they're really underwater or not and if
they actually sell things they'll have
to admit what the price is they sold it
for when they've got them marked on
their books at a higher price so that
that gets to the question of how we're
going to rescue these banks and I think
we have to recognize the banks are more
underwater than we've been told and you
know it just it's just I don't know that
for a fact it just seems obvious I mean
every week you know there's more bad
news and they're worse than they were
the week before so I mean it can't be
that all of a sudden we're going to be
getting good news instead of bad news so
it's going to get worse and worse and
there going to be hundreds of billions
underwater so if they're that far
underwater we have to start to come to
grips with that and figure out what
we're going to do about them and you
know just hiding the problem by letting
them write you know mark their things
wherever they want to mark them is not
solving any problems so if we can
actually get the prices up and get them
to sell them and clear their balance
sheets off even if it it reveals that
they're way underwater that's got to be
better and we can figure out how to
reorganize them afterwards you know spin
off part of the bank and let the rest
collapse or something so the the second
thing is you know they are hard to value
that's why the government can't possibly
figure out what to pay for them but you
know there are people who make their
living trying to value these things and
there's a huge financial system you know
there are thousands of players let them
try to value them and let them try to
buy them that's what they're supposed to
do and if they have access to borrowing
something though they'll buy more stuff
and then we'll find out what the values
are they'll be higher than they are now
but obviously the values depend on what
the macroeconomic solution is right the
default rate figures heavily in the
determining value the default rate is
going to depend on whether we take any
of these approaches in the home mortgage
market that have you involve and
advocating so it's it's a very tough
problem even even even the experts are
going to be guessing it's called the
macroeconomics of self-fulfilling
prophecy
I think it's been 90 minutes that was
what we sort of promised the panelists
it's been a really stimulating
conversation I agree I'm sorry that we
can't take all the questions that have
been lined up but thanks for coming
along and we'll you know they'll be
stimulus 2 sometime this summer in what
is my prediction and we can be back in
September with another round thank you
[Applause]